nous avons la chance de recevoir
successivement trois psychanalyste
j'accorde beaucoup d'importance à la
psychanalyse et je dois vous dire et je
le rappelle en recevant en accueillant
monsieur siboni que le sénat a beaucoup
contribué à soutenir la psychanalyse
notamment une période où elle était
menacée car l'amendement accoyer dont
l'objectif affiché était de donner de
définir les conditions d'exercice de la
profession de psychotérapeute avait un
objectif affiché qui était clair il y a
eu par contre par rapport à cet
amendement un certain nombre de
campagnes qui ont été menées qui mettait
en cause la psychanalyse dans son
existence même
je rappelle que d'autres campagnes ont
eu lieu récemment par rapport à
l'autisme et je dois dire je le dis en
préalable à ces trois auditions que pour
ma part je n'accepte pas qu'une autorité
étatique quelle qu'elle soit
euh s'érige en décideurs par rapport à
des méthodes scientifiques les méthodes
scientifiques procèdent du travail
universitaire du travail scientifique du
travail académique
et il ne revient pas à l'état
d'intervenir à cet égard donc je voulais
vous dire cela monsieur siboni quand je
dirais à vos collègues pour dire que
nous pensons que par rapport à cette
question du projet de loi ouvrant le
mariage aux couples de personnes de même
sexe nous avons souhaité bénéficier de
d'éclairage et psychanalyste tour
aujourd'hui nous recevons trois
psychanalyste vous-même puis mesure
winter pu madame roudinesco
nous avons fait appel à des personnes
connaissent sujets qui ont une
expérience reconnue qui ont d'ailleurs
les orientations différentes sur
certains sujets mais c'est l'intérêt de
la chose donc nous allons vous écoutez
je vous propose d'abord que vous
puissiez intervenir durant une quinzaine
ou une vingtaine de minutes si cela vous
convient
puis je donnerai la parole à nos deux
reporters qui sont monsieur jean pierre
michel et madame michelle meunier et
ensuite que nous puissions dialoguer
avec deux autres collègues sénateurs ici
présent que je remercie de leur présence
dont monsieur daniel sibony vous savez
la parole
je vous remercie et merci aussi de me
nommer par mon nom car je vois que sur
le set à fish je suis jean daniel sibony
c'est je suis daniels enyele et envers
la pancarte délire pur de concret c'est
du bon côté de retourner et vous voyez
là donc du coup sur l'autre j'étais un
phénomène qui du point de vue de la
psychanalyse est intéressant c'est à
dire que chacun voit votre vrai nom mais
vous ne voyez pas votre vrai nom et
c'est quelque chose qui a été pensée par
les autorités du sénat d'ailleurs ça
fait partie du subconscient des
autorités du sénat oui monsieur boni
bravo ne vous laissez pas alors nous
c'est monté absolument car nous sommes
un bon jab et nous sommes en plein dans
le sujet c'est la question du nom de la
façon de nommer les choses et je vais
d'abord vous dire que et avant d'être
psychanalyste j'étais chercheur en
mathématiques en philosophie et donc ce
n'est pas uniquement comme psychanalyste
que j'interviens et j'apprécie je trouve
positif que les psychanalystes soit
divisée sur la question comme d'ailleurs
sur beaucoup d'autres ce qui témoigne du
fait que chacun investi différemment ce
qu'il entend par symbolique transmission
même névrose etc
je peux comprendre que des
psychanalystes est été affolés de ne pas
retrouver dans les familles
homoparentales ou dans
le mariage homosexuel des repérages pour
fondamentaux comme lydie peu et je peux
témoigner
de par mon expérience que on peut faire
confiance à des groupes à des familles
humaines de toutes sortes pour exister
vivre se reproduire transmettre de la
vie de l'amour et du non amour sans se
conformer à des schémas préalable
fusse-t-il ceux de la psychanalyste
c'est dire que ma position peut vous
sembler singulière dans mes recherches
récentes je l'appellerai plutôt
singulièrement universel et je m'en
expliquerai puisque je n'ai rien contre
le fait que des zooms un couple
d'homosexuels adopte un enfant ou est un
enfant par procréation
je n'ai rien contre le fait qu'on
célèbre l'union de d'un couple
homosexuel avec toute la solennité voulu
ce qui me fait problème c'est de changer
le sens de certains mots qui entraîne en
cascade des changements tout à fait
étonnant jeu et aider changement
étonnant qui seront relayées par une
réalité cette fois-ci clinique que
beaucoup de gens ignorent ont dix
couples homosexuels retrouve sa
sympathique moi j'ai aidé lemos les
homosexuels de toutes sortes à le rester
a cessé de l'être à assumer plus
etc ce n'est pas du tout ce qui le
problème
je vais citer deux ou trois phrases qui
m'ont surpris je lis dans l'article du
monde d'une sociologue martine gross
qu'il est bon qu'une femme puisse
demander ou de sperme pour que sa
compagne puisse être fécondés je trouve
que c'est différent d'une femme demande
du sperme pour être fécondée ce qui est
le droit et qui existent dans toutes
sortes de pays sauf la france en israël
je vais souvent à jérusalem d une des
femmes seules peuvent être fécondée
peuvent adopter etc
il n'ya pas certaines limites qu'on a
imposé ici je dirais presque pour le
plaisir de les surmonter par le mariage
dit pour tous
comme si c'était la seule manière de les
surmonter
hélas il y a une espèce de sophismes
donc le mariage c'est l'union
je dirais de deux jouissance
radicalement hétérogènes sous le signe
d'une certaine légalité et cette union l
uni évidemment les deux différents et je
dirais qu'elle fait travailler
cette différence autrement dit définir
le mariage redéfinir le mariage par
l'union du même on dit que ça n'enlève
rien aux autres
c'est assez surprenant
parce que dira que ça enlève ça voudrait
dire que c'est de l'ordre d'un à voir ce
qu'on enlève c'est de l'ordre de la voir
or il s'agit ici d'un mot qui relève de
l'être on dit pas j'ai un mariage sauf
si je dois y aller
tout à l'heure on dit on dit nous sommes
mariés ont dit je suis marié on utilise
le verbe être autrement dit et faire
passer quelque chose de l'ordre de la
voir de leurs deux lettres sur le plan
de la voir est une méconnaissance d'un
certain coup de force qu'on opère
évidemment ce coup de force
j'ai lu le texte de la loi et j'ai vu
déjà les répercussions sur des
nominations sur des noms qui avaient je
dirais leur droit d'exister je ne dis
pas qu'ils avaient leur sacralité
c'est très important de voir que dans
cette affaire on a fait feu de tout bois
de part et d'autre dans un certain
affolement
on a prétendu qu'on touche et un lien
sacré le lien du mariage n'est sacré que
chez ceux qui le sacralise et il y a
tout un dégradé tout une gradation de
niveau de charge symbolique qu'on petit
maître jusqu'à la transe en danse très
haut
alors que dieu s'il existe n'a jamais
marié personne mais au niveau le plus
élémentaire c'est le sens d'un mot ce
sens il est attesté dans les
dictionnaires jusqu'à des éditions toute
récente que là encore on fait pour
anticiper le changement est normalement
dans les zi
yo je dirais honnête depuis des siècles
c'est l'union d'un homme et d'une femme
pour moi le fait que l'union d'un homme
et d'une femme
la simple l'union d'un homme et d'une
femme sous le signe d'une légalité
le fait que cette union ne trouve plus
de mots pour être nommé dans sa
spécificité est un problème et le texte
de loi
en témoigne puisqu'ils n'y figure plus
mari et femme mais époux il n'y figure
plus pères et mères mes parents ça pose
problème
moi j'ai entendu dans mon cabinet
psychanalytique une personne une jeune
personne qui venait de se marier qui
était furieuse qui m'a dit mais je veux
avoir droit à ma différence moi aussi
pourquoi le fait d'honorer la différence
chez une minorité impliquerait de la
faire perdre à une majorité et donc vous
allez entendre presque une ritournelle
dans les remarques que je vais vous
faire et cette ritournelle c fallait-il
pour donner le droit
or au conjoint d'un couple homosexuel si
le premier décède pour lui donner des
droits qu'ils ne soient plus quelqu'un
de rien fallait-il pour ça introduire ce
sens tout autre du mot mariage et faire
disparaître des mots aussi essentiels
que père et mère du texte de loi vont
dire et comme le conseil constitutionnel
mais on espère bien que ses mots
resteront dans les documents de la vie
quotidienne comme ils disent mais après
tout
le texte de loi c'est un papier qui
appartient à tout le monde le fait que y
soient effacés ce qu'ils nomment de
façon spécifique ces différences c'est
un coup de force linguistique c'est je
dirais que celui qui parle est celui qui
se passionnent légèrement pour cette
affaire c'est je dirais plutôt
l'écrivain j'ai écrit 36 livres c'est
mon activité principale à côté de celle
de psychanalystes et dire que certains
mots vont et être déchargées vide et
transformer est quelque chose qui me
gêne beaucoup
vous me direz vous en vous faisant des
bruits et bien sûr je mens débrouillerai
et les enfants qui dans un qui dans ce
couple de femmes et verrons bien que la
femme qui a demandé un don de sperme
pour féconder sa compagne se posera
comme père et qu'ils auront donc pour
père effectif
une femme et d'autres pour mr un homme
ce qui correspond à l'observation
clinique
ai-je dit tout à l'heure mais je n'avais
pas fermer ma parenthèse c'est que
l'observation clinique et quotidienne
vous montrera que dans un couple
homosexuel au moufia il y en a toujours
un qui est plus femme que l'autre plus
féminin que l'homme ou bien plus
masculin que sa compagne féminine
autrement dit et lorsqu'on voit à la
télé des des lieux où ce mariage homo a
été inscrit et que l'un des deux hommes
dit eh ben vous voyez lui ce n'est pas
mon ami
ce n'est pas mon copain c'est mon mari
et j'attendais que la caméra se tourner
vers l'autre et qu'il dise quoi
ou bien il dit et bien moi je suis sa
femme et on aura un homme qui dit je
suis une femme sans être un transsexuel
qui sont des personnes tout à fait
honorable et qui d'ailleurs tiennent
beaucoup à la différence sexuelle ou
bien on aura deux maris puisqu'il n'ya
pas d'autre alternative
ça c'est au niveau du vécu au niveau de
la réalité alors si on veut entrer dans
les détails il est clair dès le début
que cette loi sur le mariage pour tous
ceux tout ce qui est mis à la place de
homosexuels comme si tous été marqués de
cette homosexualité ou comme si le mode
les homosexuels répondait pour tous ou
comme s'ils étaient essentiellement
excluant jusque là le mariage alors
qu'il n'était pas exclu en ce sont les
familles qui étaient excluante souvent
pour un certain temps le temps de
digérer la chose et de se réjouir
ensuite de ce que finalement la vie
reprenne ses droits
donc le ce mariage pour tous cette loi
du mariage dit pour tous c'était
clairement et c'est évidemment la
première étape d'une loi sur la
filiation sûr puisque
le mot mariage comporte c'est sa valeur
même une présomption
autrefois on disait de paternité on peut
dire de pater de parentalité de
filiation donc est d'ailleurs la loi
mentionne déjà l'adoption comme si elle
traiter le cas le plus simple qui n'est
pas le plus simple
et sachant que dans la réalité concrète
là aussi et j'aimerais être présents
lorsqu'on décidera de dans une
commission d'attribuer et un enfant
plutôt à un couple homosexuel car un
couple hétérosexuel mais ça c'est une
autre affaire
j'ajoute quand même d'une façon tout à
fait incidente que si on veut
approfondir cette question de la famille
de des nouvelles familles de de la
filiation
il est clair j insiste que on peut
donner tous les droits nécessaires aux
enfants à opérer à son et à son ami ou à
son compagnon à la mère et à sa compagne
sans bouleverser ce sens et sans expulsé
le sens normal ordinaire banal de
certains mots mais qui garde au fil des
temps leurs vibrations étonnante alors
au fond je dirais qu'il s'agit de
permettre à des personnes qui ne peuvent
pas ou ne veulent pas recourir à l'autre
sexe
ne serait-ce qu'une fois pour avoir des
enfants
il s'agit de leur permettre d'en avoir
quand même
fallait-il pour cela faire ce
chamboulement
ce n'est pas sûr il se peut et là c'est
plutôt le
je dirait le philosophe qui vous parle
il se peut que toucher à l'autre sexe
ne serait-ce qu'une fois ce soit comme
la dette que prix à payer
depuis la nuit des temps pour avoir un
enfant
et quand un sens ce pourrait être une
preuve d'amour ou une épreuve en vue
d'obtenir cet enfant les couples hommes
femmes qui recourent à l'assistance ont
des rapports sexuels
l'assistance n'est pas fait pour en
tenir lieu
il arrive très rarement qu'un couple
homme femme se présente déclarent qu'ils
ont de très bonnes relations n'est pas
sexuel et demande un don et le cac se
résout selon l'humeur du chef de service
si les boeufs
il laisse passer sinon il pose le
problème et l'issue peut être différente
il faut comprendre que le recours à la
technique peut permettre d'éviter
d'affronter certains problèmes mais ceci
reste intacte et se déplacent ailleurs
est ce que le but de la technique et
d'éluder les problèmes ou de mieux les
affronter dans le cas des homosexuels le
rejet de l'autre sexe
passé sous silence dans le recours à la
technique s'exprimera évidemment par la
suite lorsque j'entends une femme dira
je le veux pas me coltiner un père pour
élever mon enfant je me pose des
questions sur la transmission ou normal
dans un couple homosexuel du rejet de
l'autre sexe qui a structuré ce couple
comme homosexuels il n'est pas sûr que
dans les couples ordinaires
le refus de l'homosexualité soit ce qui
a structuré ce couple on se présente pas
quand on est un homme et une femme
mourir voilà francine et moi couples
hétérosexuels
on ne définit pas les gens par leur
sexualité est donc là du fait qu' on
entre on va je vais vous montrer comment
la loi entre dans entre dans cette
intimité sexuelle mais une fois qu'on y
entre et pour en sortir c'est assez
délicat et on a tiré un voile pudique
sur le fait on a été tellement obsédé
par l'homophobie
l' accusation d'homophobie que on a
oublié que dans ces couples et ces
familles il a le rejet de l'autre sexe
fait partie des données et pourquoi pas
mais ça peut permettre de ne pas
idéaliser à l'excès c'est famille qui
existent qui sont réelles pour lesquels
les études qu'on a fait qui montre
qu'elles sont superbes sont des études
évidemment partiels mais peu importe la
réalité c'est que elle existe mais mais
ce qui est très surprenant c'est qu'au
nom de cette réalité on a procédé à un
autre déni de réalité qui est dénié la
réalité de relation comme mariage père
mère et c'est alors jeu en répondant à
vos questions j'entrerai plus dans le
détail notamment dans le fait que fait
on a mis en valeur et que
un couple que j'ai un couple
hétérosexuel fille qui recourent à la
procréation assistée
eh bien il réduit le donneur à une
cellule 1 du sperme qu'il a donnée et
qu'au contraire les nouveaux couples
vont réhabiliter cette personne cet
argument que j'ai souvent entendu et
particulièrement malhonnête parce que un
couple de femmes qui recourent à un don
de sperme 9 au cra cet homme lorsque
l'enfant grandit et questionnera
n'invoquera cet homme que comme donneur
de sperme est sûrement pas comme père
puisque justement il n'est pas question
de l'introduire comme père dans cet
univers-là et d'autre c'est intéressant
tout de même cette petite aspect qui n'a
l'air de rien mais il vous illustre
aussi comment d'avoir changé le sens
d'un mot va entraîner des choses comme
celles ci la levée de l'anonymat lors du
don pour des couples homosexuels
féminins elle est évidente elle s'impose
d'elle-même mais il s'est même levée de
l'anonymat pour des couples
hétérosexuels qui recourent aux dents ou
donc pose un problème énorme
ils ne veulent pas mais pour de toutes
autres raisons de ce personnage ils ne
peuvent pas l'intégrer et donc
curieusement la levée de l'anonymat d'un
côté entraînera le secret de l'autre car
ils ne diront rien j'alignerai d'autres
phénomène intéressant au fur et à mesure
de vos questions merci merci monsieur
daniel sibony
je voulais vous dire que nous n'avons
sans doute pas tous lu vos vingt six
ouvrages
26 30 36 excusez-moi 36 mais que nous
avons tout le temps j'ai le temps mais
je n'ignore ni d'entre d'eux - l'origine
en partage ni don de soi ou partage de
soi ce qui est déjà quelque chose bien
alors maintenant nous donnons la parole
à jean pierre michel rapporteur ma
question sera assez simple peut être
trop simple entre votre introduction au
niveau développement il ya quand même un
fossé où les durées busson pose aucun
problème
et ensuite vous êtes heurter par les
mots qui sont employés dans la loi mais
la loi ce n'est pas de la psychanalyse
c'est des mots des mots qui ont
d'ailleurs des antécédents il ya une
jurisprudence de ces mots et l'autre ces
mots sont employées ce qu'ils veulent
dire quelque chose au regard de la loi
donc le mot mariage veut dire quelque
chose regarde la loi peut-être pas au
regard à votre regard
mais je n'en sais rien mais au regard de
la loi le mot mariage veut dire quelque
chose et donc moi je prétends que c'est
mon mariage s'applique très bien à deux
personnes de même sexe comme il
s'applique à des personnes de sexe
différent alors fille fait vous pose
aucun problème
quelles solutions préconisez-vous en
termes de mots en tête d'appellation
comment va-t-on nommé ce couple comment
va-t-on nommer ses parents comment
va-t-on nommer leur rapport
si je fais données de la parole à madame
michelle meunier qui rapporteur au titre
de la commission des affaires sociales
michel merci oui monsieur siboni donc je
vous ai écouté avec attention et ça a
commencé d'ailleurs par un lapsus
révélateur puisque votre nom et votre
prénom plutôt été lipotomie zélus donc
l'importance du nom et de nommer moi je
voulais vous demander en tant que
psychanalyste
comment vous pouvez participer contribué
avec le législateur à faire évoluer
justement c'est ses symboles surtout
quand ils représentent une part
d'injustice et d'exclusion si l'on reste
sur la question du mariage de couples de
mêmes personnes est ce que les
psychanalystes peuvent aider oui le
législateur à cette évolution de par
ailleurs en passant sur la question du
mot mais si je pense que la référence
que vous avez que vous nous avez aussi
au travers des mots que vous avez donnée
est quand même très biologique est ce
que vous pensez pas que c'est peut-être
là aussi une difficulté à penser un
modèle différent que ce sens normal ou
ce sens banale dont vous avez parlé pour
désigner le mariage
ensuite peut-être une dernière question
sur la dernière partie quand vous avez
abordé la question du don de sperme et
et l'anonymat moi je veux vous dire que
tous les couples infertiles qui ont
aujourd'hui recours à la
un pma sont après des couples de parents
dont l'enfant ignore totalement son
géniteur mais c'est qui est son père et
qui est sa mère et sont des enfants qui
vivent très bien dans leur famille donc
je voulais aussi vous dire cela
d'ici que parce que je crois que le
malentendu existe mais il faut pas non
plus qu'on le pousse un certaine limite
car bien sûr et je suis au courant que
dans ces couples infertiles qui
recourent aux dons c'est évident que les
enfants savent qui est leur père et leur
mère
et c'est essentiel puisque la filiation
pour moi elle tient justement au mot à
l'engagement symbolique et non pas au
fait qu' il y a eu un donneur j'ai cité
cet exemple juste comme cas particulier
des effets qu'il y aura sur des couples
hétérosexuels qui recourent aux dons si
on lève l'anonymat comme c'est presque
normal l'anonymat du nom pour des
couples homosexuels féminins voyez vous
donc
et ne me dites pas que dans ces couples
qui recourent aux dont le père est
d'abord un père symbolique
disons car c'est justement non seulement
la réalité mais c'est ce que je souhaite
c'est un effet de parole rien dans ma
contestation de la pertinence dessus du
changement du mot mariage n'en appellent
à la biologie
je ne dis pas que le mot mariage ne
convient pas un couple homosexuel
parce qu'il n'ya pas de biologie d'abord
c'est faux puisque dans le cas dans les
deux cas il y aura biologie même dans le
cas d'une mère porteuse pour un couple
de deux hommes
il y aura du biologique mais ce n'est
pas ce qui compte
la filiation humaine est avant tout
symbolique et donc
je reviens à la question de départ
et comment va-t-on nommé et ces couples
mais je ne voit pas d'objection à ce que
un couple de c'est le cas d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui je connais beaucoup va
beaucoup de quelques je connais quelques
couples homosexuels hommes qui élèvent
des enfants des enfants que l'un d'eux a
conçu avant de se séparer de sa femme et
de se découvrir homosexuels et bien cet
enfant il a un père et il a un ami du
père et il a une mère et c'est très bien
si les choses partent je dirais dès le
départ dès l'origine
c'est à dire si cet enfant non pas comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
mais si on le prend à 6 mois ou à un
mois ou à ce bref à sa naissance quand
il vient de naître de l'une des deux
femmes ou de la mère porteuse car il n'y
en aura pas d'autre et bien très bien il
aura cet homme comme père puisqu'il le
reconnaît et le compagnon de l'homme
aura des droits importants qui feront
que si le père de sept enfants meurent
et les liens avec avec le compagnon
peuvent demeurer le compagnon et
protéger etc
il faut quand même bien voir que si on a
créé beaucoup de problèmes
c'est parce que il me semble qu'on a
pris la chose à l'envers c'est à dire on
a dit mais voyons et si les autres ne
peuvent pas se marier c'est qu'ils sont
exclus non et un tabouret n'est pas
exclue du statut de chaises un tabouret
c'est pas une chaise c'est pas égal il
n'ya pas d'exclusion
chaque objet chaque être à son naissance
mais là c'est une relation c'est pas une
un territoire c'est pas une propriété
donc on a pensé il faut d'abord réparer
cette exclusion est en fait c'est parce
que tout à fait ce qu'on a fait on a
doublé la chose on a dit et vous savez
toutes les fois que j'ai questionné des
personnes car j'en ai questionnés
beaucoup sur ce mariage homo tout me
disais mais oui pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas un mariage homosexuel qu'est-ce que
ça enlève aux autres alors je dis ça
change le sens des mots
c'est très important pin 10 mai il
serait temps que certaines aberrations
cesse comme quoi un psychanalyste me dis
eh bien par exemple je connais une
famille où le père a eu recours à un don
de sperme ou l'homme a eu recours à un
don de sperme avec sa femme pour avoir
un fils mais la mère n'a pas voulu
la mère de l'homme n'a pas voulu la
belle-mère
parce que l a dit il faut que ce soit
vraiment ton fils sinon je ne le
reconnaît pas jeudi mais quel rapport
avec mariage tous ces problèmes
je les rencontre avec des couples
ordinaires
autrement dit chaque fois qu'on a voulu
justifier cette loi on a importé des
choses
des questions qui peuvent se résoudre
sans elle autrement dit il est resté
comme argument qu un seul qui est
l'égalité hors légalité encore une fois
l'égalité c'est l'égalité de la quantité
des droits vous et moi nous ne serons
jamais égaux mais nous pouvons nous
battre pour avoir les mêmes droits
c'est ça l'égalité aujourd'hui on abuse
mot égalité en en la confondant presque
avec l'identité
on s'identifie et à l'autre et cette
identification devrait tenir lieu
d'égalité or l'identification c'est le
vertige
l'égalité c'est chacun sort ses cartes
de jeu pour un certain jeu social pas
pour tout jeu d'ailleurs parce qu'il
n'aura jamais deux personnes n'auront
jamais les mêmes cartes mais au regard
de la loi
il faut qu'elles aient les mêmes droits
c'est ça pour moi l'égalité
donc cette histoire de comment les
nommer pour moi ne pose pas de problème
ils portent les noms de ils ont la mer
qu'ils ont et l'autre la compagne de la
mère ne peut pas s'appeler seconde mère
et ne peut pas avoir un statut qui
ferait de la première le père je dirais
que la loi ne sait pas qu'elle cautionne
une mascarade mais une mascarade qui a
lieu dans l'intimité et on ne va pas les
surveiller ce que les gens transmettent
et ce qu'ils disent dans l'intimité dont
se mêlent déjà bien trop en définissant
des gens par leur sexualité
donc la question de moi je peux vous
aider à nommer à étudier les effets sur
la nomination mais je n'ai pas vu
d'exclusion si ce n'est au niveau de l'
injustice flagrante qui a toujours
existé dans ce pays envers les
homosexuels
et là je comble ce fossé que monsieur le
sénateur vous avez perçu tout à l'heure
mais qui pour moi n'en est pas un j'ai
dit que par mon propre caractère par mon
expérience par ma fréquentation en tant
que psychothérapeute et en tant que
citoyen je n'ai pas d'objection je n'ai
pas dit que ça ne pose pas
problème j'ai dit je n'ai pas
d'objection à ce qu'on donne tous les
droits nécessaires à ces homos famille
mais pas qu'on les prenne comme repère
pour redéfinir quelque chose qui
concerne l'immense majorité des autres
si c'était fait de retour qui est
stupéfiant et qui ferait penser à
presque une manoeuvre un peu
machiavélique
c'est que des gens voudraient promouvoir
un nouveau type de famille considère que
l'ancien type de famille est caduque
alors que avec sa caducité ces problèmes
y voyagent pas mal puisque c'est rien de
moins que les couples qui ont reproduit
l'humanité et heureusement quimper n'est
jamais le père qu'on aurait voulu et
qu'une mère n'est jamais celle qu on
aurait rêvé mais c'est très bien et ça
continue qu'il y ait des homos famille
qu'on les laisse se développer ce qu'on
leur donne leur droit etc mais pas qu'on
redéfinisse à partir d'elle et à partir
d'une trouvaille technique qui est tout
même assez limité qu'on redéfinisse à
partir de là ce que doit être la vraie
pensée de la famille et de la filiation
merci beaucoup monsieur daniel sibony
je vais maintenant de la parole à nos
collègues j'ai déjà une inscrits qui m'a
même classe s qui lie à d'autres
inscrits monsieur le sert donc madame
claisse merci monsieur le président en
face à attendre patiemment ma question
va être vraiment sans doute basique et
concrète
j'entends bien notamment tous les
problèmes de nominations en matière de
filiation effectivement on peut
concevoir deux mères de pères peut-être
un peu un peu difficilement en ce qui
concerne le statut
des personnes homosexuelles qui se
marierait dans le cadre de ce texte de
ce texte de loi
moi je connais des couples homosexuels
autour de moi qui sont pas mariés mais
mes pacsés et qui s'appellent
mutuellement parce qu'en l'occurrence il
s'agit d'hommes mon conjoint ou est-ce
qu'on peut pas imaginer au moins déjà
pour résoudre ce problème de nominations
au lieu d'avoir un mari une femme qui
n'est pas une femme etc
imaginez de redéfinir des mots est
compris dans le dictionnaire qui serait
l'épousé ou le conjoint les poser
s'écrivant avec un e au 100 e selon
qu'il s'agit de couples dans goutta est
ce que vous pensez que ce genre de
choses qui viendrait sans doute petit à
petit avec le temps et avec l'habitude
ne pourrait résoudre au moins une partie
des questions que vous soulevez bien je
vais donner aussi monsieur président moi
je vais prendre des précautions
oratoires comme virginie klès parce que
mes compétences en psychanalyse sont
extrêmement limitées et je souhaiterais
effectivement être sûr devra bien
compris un certain nombre de choses donc
il me semble avoir compris par exemple
deux choses que ce ce mariage homosexuel
que la loi se propose de mettre en
oeuvre risquait d'avoir des conséquences
dommageables sur le mariage traditionnel
sorte d'effet de pollution ce qui est
quand même important parce que très
souvent l'argument qui est donné c'est
l'argument consistant à dire on crée une
liberté supplémentaire mais on ne retire
rien effectivement à la liberté telle
qu'elle existe donc un premier point qui
moi m'interpelle le second point là
aussi si j'ai bien compris vous estimez
donc dans d'antan
les compétences qui sont les vôtres que
dans l'intérêt d'un certain nombre de
couples homosexuels et dans l'intérêt de
l'enfant qu'il souhaite avoir
il pourrait être parfois plus important
qu'il la fasse si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi la concession de l'altérité à dire
pour que l'enfant puisse venir sans
intervention de pma ou de gpa et que la
mise en place du coupe du mariage
homosexuel risque au contraire de les
enfermer davantage dans ce que
j'appellerais peut-être une espèce des
terreaux phobie qui finalement pourrait
pour certains d'entre eux avoir des
conséquences malsaine pourrait
simplement être sûr d'avoir bien compris
ce que vous me disiez si vous voulez
bien répondre monsieur si oui aux deux
orateurs et d'avoir un madame l'oratrice
vous voulez dire vous avez fini la
question ah bon d'accord je pensais que
vous voulez ma réponse avant de poser
les bonnes questions
donc comment d'accord bien alors il ya
madame claisse alors monsieur le cerf
est bon et vous savez le problème de
l'appellation du nom est un problème
très vaste et je veux dire est très bien
de quoi un couple de deux hommes un
couple homosexuel s'appelle conjoint
imaginons la loi très bien les notes
comme conjoint ce que le sens de mon
intervention s'était qu' il faut quand
même sur le plan de la filiation veiller
à ce que l'enfant ne va pas appeler ses
deux chaires conjoint il va appeler mais
c'est très important imaginez un enfant
qui court vers ces deux sommes ouverts
l'un de ces deux hommes
il va dire papa et il va dire ou alors
il appellera l'autre par son prénom
voilà il va pas dire conjoint voilà et
entre eux très bien il s'appelle
conjoint
mais ce que je mettais en avant comme
danger majeur essentiel c'est justement
cette disparition de nom deux mots
essentiels important spécifiques
même si je m'abstiens de les charger
symboliquement religieusement
métaphysiquement et c'est peu au sens le
plus basique du terme voilà alors je dis
je serais d'accord que vous ayez compris
ça mais je parlerai pas de pollution
je dirais que healy à la langue
vous savez la langue les mots de la
langue ce n'est pas une espèce de
pelouse sur laquelle on se promène puis
on cueille des fleurs on cueille un mot
puis un autre
la langue nous traversent nous faisons
partie de la langue en même temps que
nous là parlons autrement dit et je
faisais allusion à cette globalité qui
fait que vous bouleverser vous casser le
sens d'un mot ça rejaillit sur d'autres
mots et salées des formes salle et casas
les transforme pas forcément on pourrait
dire et après tout pourquoi pas eh bien
ça les transforme
mais là se pose une question est ce que
ce n'est pas trop cher payé que de
réparer les injustices qu'a commise la
société envers les homos ou envers ces
familles homoparentales ont le
reconnaissant pas des droits est ce que
ce n'est pas une lettre une espèce de
paiement par surenchère que de payer par
la disparition de certains mots
essentiels ou par l'effacement ou la
distorsion de quelques autres voilà et
si vous voulez une dinde d'une façon je
dirais peut-être plus philosophique je
dirais que cette loi le législateur a
très bien compris il est très
clairvoyant aussi il a très bien compris
que
les gens qui se marient sait s'il
invoque dieu une transcendance du
symbolique etc
ils le font en général avec leurs
coutumes au mariage religieux etc
quand ils se marient ils viennent
s'affilier ils viennent adhérer à un mot
qui a une longue histoire de
transmission
ils se marient comme le père s'est marré
comme les parents ce sont les
grands-parents les aïeuls et c'est donc
ils viennent prendre la suite d'une
transmission et le législateur dit mais
qu'à cela ne tienne les couples homos se
marieront pas besoin d'une transmission
au nom de la loi concret pour ça et oui
mais là il ya un côté coup de force
origines qui fait un peu tremblé est-ce
que ce coup de force là on a tous les
éléments pour le poser c'est quelque
chose
le conseil constitutionnel a dit je
crois réformes majeures ou quelque chose
d énorme important enfin maîtresses non
mais j'ai vu lesquels les quelques le
conseil d'état pardon excusez moi lapsus
mardi mal considérés il a dit quelques
mots de mise en garde et cetera
mais qu'ils disent sur tout mais c'est
énorme cette chose là et peut-être que
c'est sa façon d'alerter sur le prix
payé pour tout autre chose que l'égalité
maintenant pièce oui j'entends bien ce
que vous dites mais dans la société
française en tout cas quand on est passé
du mariage religieux comme seul mariage
reconnu au mariage civil
on a aussi quelque part là loi aussi
créé un peu ce coup de force dont vous
parlez non nous ça n'avait pas grand
chose à voir non pas elle n'a pas changé
le sens elle a dit il suffit de deux
citoyens de sexe différent qui viennent
tamponner leur lien à la devant
l'autorité civile pour que ça fasse
mariage ils n'ont pas beau
la bénédiction divine et ils n'ont pas
besoin de se référer à cette tradition
donc hélas allégé et les conditions
d'exercice elle n'a pas changé le sens
du mot me suis dit moi je suis très
intéressé par le vos propos je les
trouve finalement à l'anti pose de ce
que nous disait madame françoise
héritier qui nous disait nous sommes
dans des combinatoires il y aura
beaucoup de combinatoire il y en a eu
énormément depuis le début de l'histoire
de l'humanité il n'y en aura encore
est ce que vous faites là doit être mis
à sa juste place
vous avez parlé du langage et on peut
parler aussi des lois
vous savez que nous vivons dans des
structures le grand linguiste yann
streiff a dit qu'une structure c'était
une entité autonome de dépendances ce
interne c'est à dire que la structure
est une entité autonome mais à
l'intérieur d'elle même chaque élément
ne se définit que par rapport aux autres
une loi fait changer l'édifice des lois
la constellation la galaxie un mot qui
changent de sens ce qui est le cas ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'une loi
changerait le sens d'un mot est temps d
un mot qui changent de sens fait que
d'autres mots changent de sens et que le
système se redistribuent mais c'est une
loi générale voyez-vous ce que je veux
dire
autrement dit si on veut éviter les
effets qui serait funeste de cela il
faudrait arrêter de légiférer ou de
parler car souvent en parlant nous
donnons à notre nom à notre sens
vont ils mallarmé parler de donner un
sens plus pur homo de la cité donc à la
fois je comprends ce que vous dites mais
je ne comprends pas cette sorte de
terreur que vous manifestez à l'idée
qu'il y ait des changements dans la
structure
il y à tous les changements dans la
alors je citerai un sculpteur chillida
qui a renouvelé énormément la perception
de l'espace
à partir de cette idée il a dit
l'architecturé ambiante le dégoûter un
peu et s'est tourné vers la sculpture
et il a dit pour être vraiment libre il
faut avoir un point fixe
si dans notre conversation on peut se
permettre des malentendus des équivoques
des changements de sens c'est parce que
il y a certains points fixes relatifs
aux mots de même la structure je serai
bien ennuyé pour vous dire dans quelle
structure nous sommes ce que je peux
dire c'est que certains liens certaines
transmissions ont été assez
structurantes pour que quand elles
disent fonctionne on puisse ressaisir
rétablir etc
autrement dit je ne pense pas que l idée
de dire que et une loi va change le sens
d'un mot mais et ça va réagir sur le
reste
et finalement ça pourrait s'équilibrer
je vous demande de me donner un seul
exemple où un mot identifiant a changé
de sens
je prends le mot ennuis au xvième siècle
il avait un sens terrible aujourd'hui
c'est rien du tout c'est l'ennui est ce
qu'il y à un mot est ce que j'en ai
cherché en vain un mot identifiant comme
je suis marié il est c'est mon père
c'est sa femme et c est ce que
connaissait un mot identifiant qui a
changé de sens c'est ça ne peut se faire
que par un coup de force d'une identité
qui se réunir et que c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs l'idée de référendum pour
cette loi ce n'est pas seulement pour
contester l'argument politique assez
assez discutable qui dirait que la
majorité des français à voter pour ce
point alors qu'il est évident que onu
ont peut calculer la probabilité pour
que la majorité qui a élu monsieur
hollande est choisi
unanimement ce point on trouverait une
probabilité très faible
donc ce n'est pas lille arguments du
référendum ce n'est pas pour contrer cet
argument politique fallacieux je dirais
que dans la bouche de certains
c'est presque un recours à une
souveraineté publics présentent une
façon de dire non c'est trop énorme
il faut que tous se prononcer ils disent
voilà on veut ce changement énorme t oui
d'accord
bon moi je voudrais parler longuement je
ne le ferai pas parce qu'il ya un
horaire mais enfin franchement monsieur
daniel sibony
je ne comprends rien à la différence
qu'il y aurait entre un mot identifiant
et un mot qui ne serait pas identifiée
je ne comprends rien à l'idée qu'il y
aurait des mots qui serait identifiant
et geek donc ne changerai pas de sens et
d'autres nour qui changerait de sens je
ne sais pas eu il y a des milliers
de contre exemple allez-y prenez le mot
rien rires n'ont rien rien rien
et oui le mot rien il vient du latin res
rem et qui signifie quelque chose
il est devenu le contraire comme on dit
rien et on dit mais il y a des restes de
l'ancien sens comme quand on dit rien
vous comprenez rien
ce n'est pas tout à fait rien quand vous
dites c'est marrant ça vient d'une
racine marque a donné j'en ai marre qui
renvoie aux côtés sinistre des choses
quand vous dites certainement c'est que
ce n'est pas certain sans doute c'est
qu'il y a un doute mais je vais pas vous
faire un développement sur le sujet mais
je dis monsieur siboni parce qu'il faut
quand même qu'on soit clair entre nous
que la considération dogmatique que vous
venez de faire selon laquelle il y
aurait des mots identifiants et des mots
non identifiant ne signifie rien et que
le fait qu'il y aurait des mots qui
changerait de sens et d'autres qui ne
sent ce débat de chance est aussi une
déclaration qui ne repose sur rien
donc je me permets de le dire car la
parole est libre
voilà comment comment mais absolument
mon cher collègue d'ailleurs je vous
donne immédiatement la parole vous
permettez vous vous permettez que je
réponde à l'exemple que vous avez donné
l'exemple que vous avez donnée c'est
comme le celui que j'ai donné le mot
ennuis on dit pas je suis en ennui dit
je suis ennuyé s'est pas remis parmi les
états d'âme qui peuvent arriver
tandis que je suis marié ou je suis
français tient ses identifiants ça fait
partie de du fonds identificatoires et
si vous dites france est dorénavant ça
voudra dire et on change le sens ce sont
là les gens diront mais tant qu on est
donc il y a des mots qui sont
identifiant s'est excusé moi de ne pas
avoir développer davantage ce point mais
et le temps ne s'y prête pas le mot
mariage le mot père le mot mère et etc
ce sont des mots avec lesquels des gens
s'identifient voilà bien nommé je ne
conteste absolument pas le fait que les
mots et un sens mais s'il arrive qu'ils
changent de sens bien mais c'est un
sujet dont on pourrait parler très
longtemps et je ne veux pas empêcher mon
collègue revêt de me contredire
le président nous a réagi par trois
quatre autant qu'on puisse avoir un avis
mais les je suis heureux d'entendre
et je regrette parce que c'était pas
dans ce que nous avons su pas dans la
commission des lois je suis dans les
autres commissions mais c'était pas le
document que vous avez moi c'était à
partir de 15h quand c'est pour ça que
alain sommet je suis content d'avoir
entendu cette forme et très bien parce
que parce que les très très importante
ça veut dire qu'il ya des mots qui sont
construits au fil du temps qui sont me
semble-t-il la prise en compte d'une
réalité constatée et père mère une femme
et marie maps mais oui ça existe depuis
toujours sans que ce soit et donc ce
sont bien deux sont vos cibles des mots
identifiant et dont on ne tient plus
compte
est ce que le liquidateur que comme ça
du jour au lendemain à dire on n'est pas
d'accord donc au change de nature
dénommé je veux dire mon cher collègue
que je comprends pour être précis tout à
fait que vous soyez attaché au sens
profond d'un certain nombre de mots les
mots ont un sens mais ce que je
contestais de rien et aucun mot n'est
venue de rien mais ce que je contestais
je me permets de le faire et j'y crois
profondément c'est qu'on pourrait
distinguer dans la catégorie des mots de
deux sortes de mots des mots qui serait
immuable et d'autres qui ne le serait
pas je pense que toutes les sciences
humaines et sociales récusera cette
dichotomie
mais cela dit je ne veux pas prolonger
le débat là dessus et je veux dire que
je comprends tout à fait que l'on
veuille donner un sens plat au mot père
mère bien sûr un bien sûr c'est autre
chose
alors vous permettez et j'imagine que
mon temps de parole en temps de paroles
s'arrêtent et je pourrais vous donner un
exemple de mots identifiant qui n'arrête
pas de changer de sens mais avec une
certaine stabilité
je m'explique
moi je ne suis pas que marié je suis
juif juif est un mot dont le sens
l'identité est à la fois supposé précise
et très bon dos les très différentes les
uns diront moi je suis lui de cette
façon mais l'autre il est d'une autre
façon et c'est à voir là une identité
je dirais tout sauf lisses et pourtant
on ne pourrait pas dire eh bien ce qu'on
appellera dorénavant dès qu'on dit dès
qu'on fait ces attaques de parole qui
dit ce qu'on appellera dorénavant juifs
ou ce qu'on appellera dorénavant mariage
et bien ça sera cela c'est ce coup de
force qui est et non pas terrifiant j'ai
pas vraiment l'air terrifié mais qui
pose de vrais problèmes
merci donc monsieur si oui vous avez
compris que vous pourrez dialoguer
longue long moment avec vous par rapport
aux eaux à vos à vos positions bien sûr
mais nous avons quelque chose qui est
dirigeant qui est l'horaire la pendule
donc nous poursuivrons ce dialogue cet
identifiant bon sur lequel monsieur rv
et moi sommes d'accord c'est qu'il faut
respecter l'horaire que nous vous avons
particulièrement invités par ce qui
existe de nombreux psychanalystes de
talent et si nous nous nous sollicitions
tous les psychanalystes de talent il
nous faudrait l'année entière et encore
serait-elle trop courte parce que vous
avez écrit un livre sur
l'homoparentalité
donc vous vous êtes vraiment pencher sur
cette question spécifique
donc monsieur winter sans plus attendre
je vous donne la parole
mais monsieur le rapporteur va nous
rejoindre car monsieur le rapporteur est
très attentif
mais bien sûr vous restez là monsieur
winter vous avez la parole
je vous remercie
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs de me
fait l'honneur de m'écouter sur ce sujet
sur lequel effectivement je travaille
depuis fort longtemps maintenant puisque
le livre que vous êtes mentionné
monsieur le président a déjà deux ans
comptez une année pour l'écrire donc ça
fait au moins trois ans que je m'occupe
de ces de ces questions et certaines
choses qui se sont produites pendant le
débat parlementaire et dans les mois qui
viennent de passer ont rendu déjà en
quelque sorte un peu obsolète certaines
questions que je me posais toujours est
il qu au moment où j'ai écrit ce livre
et qui donc pas ruyant en 2010 j'étais
déjà d'avis que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire la question de l'adoption ne
posait pas de problème aussi important
que ce qui se profile à l'horizon
c'est à dire ceux de la pma et
éventuellement malgré ce qui nous est
dit du côté du gouvernement
éventuellement donc les questions liées
à la gpa donc j'insisterai puisque c'est
l'actualité un peu plus sur ces
questions là que sur la question du
mariage puisque de toute façon les
choses semblent maintenant acquise
encore que bien sûr votre rôle et je
sais bien est de permettre que la
discussion continue si elle si elle doit
et si elle plus continuer la complexité
du problème a été en quelque sorte
masqué par sa politisation
le fait que les tenants du mariage pour
tous liés nécessairement adoption et
voit d'effet domino éventuellement à la
pma et à la gpa ont classé les partisans
de celle de ce changement en
progressiste et ceux qui s'y opposent en
religieux et même en réactionnaire voire
dans certains cas qui sont extraits mais
on va pas les évoquer longuement ici en
homophobe ou que sais-je encore de bien
plus terrible il se trouve que les
choses ne se répartissent pas aussi
facilement tôt cela dans la mesure où
les religieux ne sont pas forcément du
côté qu'on croit ce qui se réfère à la
religion ne sont pas ceux qui avouent
s'y référer nécessairement et ceux qui
ne s'y réfère pas peuvent être bien
teinté de religion et je vais vous en
donner un seul exemple parce que c'est
pas là dessus que je veux m'appesantir
le plus longuement quand je lis sous la
plume d'un académicien que vous
connaissez tous qui est michel serres un
article d'abord paru dans la croix puis
ensuite plus longuement dans la revue
études qui est la revue des jésuites
michel serres qui est un philosophe
athée faire la démonstration que
l'adoption ne devrait pas nous poser de
problème parce qu'au fond elle répond au
modèle qui est celui de la sainte
famille qu'il a intitulé d'ailleurs dans
son article d'études la scène famille
sns à ina avec tous les jeux de mots que
vous voudrez il fait allusion au fait
que bien ce modèle qui pour les
théologiens chrétiens évidemment n'en
est pas un pour l'homme ce modèle qui
consiste à faire à mettre au monde un
enfant qui naît dans le père n'est pas
le père mais qui doit l'adopter et dans
la mer n'est pas la mère puisqu'elle est
vierge
ce modèle serait en quelque sorte si on
suit sa démonstration
celui-là même auquel les tenants de
l'homoparentalité
l'étonnant de l'adoption de la pma et
cetera se livreraient c'est juste une
indication pour dit
la complexité du problème est de ne pas
nous en quelque sorte nous assurer comme
ça avec une espèce de de bonne foi que
les choses sont équitablement répartis
et à vue de nez ce qu'ils sont religieux
et ceux qui sont plus du côté du
laïcisme de la république etc
d'autant que deuxième argument même dans
l'histoire de la république et dans
l'histoire des lettres
les choses sont encore plus compliqué
parce que par exemple j'ai trouvé chez
le divin marquis de sade
cette formule qui je pense ne ferait
hurler bien qu'elle soit écrite dans un
dans un texte qui est qui est celui de
encore un effort pour être républicain
cette formule qui devrait faire hurler
bien un certain nombre d'entre nous jose
assumer dit il que l'inceste devrait
être la loi de tout gouvernement dans la
fraternité et la base c'est vous dire
que on sait pas très bien où on met les
pieds
il faut faire très attention à ce qu'on
dit quand on parle de ses affaires et
surtout de la façon dont on désigne les
uns et les autres c'est à dire les
opposants et les partisans d'un projet
de loi qui mérite une discussion très
approfondie comme on vient jules la
chance d'entendre les derniers échanges
entre mon collègue daniel simoni et vous
monsieur le président effectivement une
des raisons pour lesquelles je pense que
ils ont intervention peut ne pas être
tout à fait inutile comme celle de
certains de mes collègues c'est parce
que nous devons nous donner le temps de
bien voir toutes les conséquences de ce
que nous faisons or il me semble que là
nous sommes dans un temps de
précipitations qui n'augure rien de
vraiment favorable à l'avenir de nos
enfants et à l'avenir de notre société
en tant que psychanalyste je voudrais
dire et commencer par par là après cette
introduction
je voudrais dire que la famille vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure madame
françoise héritier
la famille n'est pas un concept
psychanalytique
c'est un concept anthropologique et en
tant que psychanalyste les
anthropologues travail à leur façon mais
en tant que psychanalyste
la famille n'est pas une de mes
préoccupations majeures de même que
candy la famille je veux dire les
modalités de la famille la façon dont
les familles s'organisent au cours du
temps et dans l'espace ne fait pas
l'objet d'un dogme psychanalytique quel
qu'il soit et il n'est pas vrai quoi
qu'en disent certains de mes autres
collègues il n'est pas vrai que la
psychanalyse et notamment freud aurait
en quelque sorte modifié de fond en
comble ce qui ce qui aurait été la
famille bourgeoise du xixème siècle
freud n'a jamais eu cette intention et
les occurrences dans l'oeuvre de freud
qui concerne la famille se comptent sur
les doigts de la main même le mot
famille par contre la question de la
filiation et la question comme l'a dit
dans le peu que j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure daniel sibony la question des
mots qui sont utilisés pour parler de la
filiation et pour transmettre le fait
d'avoir à se préoccuper de comment un
enfant se situe par rapport à l'histoire
de ce qu'ils ont engendrez ça ça
intéresse le psychanalyste ça intéresse
ce que freud lui-même appelait
l'inconscient parentale est évidemment
on peut pas demander au législateur
d'intégrer dans les lois qu'il fait
d'intégrer la dimension de l'inconscient
mais on peut quand même lui demander de
tenir compte du fait que une découverte
majeure a été fait au début du 20e
siècle et que cette découverte nous a
amenés à considérer que en plus de la
réalité à laquelle chacun d'entre nous
est confronté il existe ce qui est la
découverte majeure de freud il existe
une réalité psychique
et que cette réalité psychique elle est
faite de toutes sortes de choses de
l'inconscient du conscient du rêve du
fantasme de tous de toutes sortes de
choses qui font que nous avons être
attentif à la façon dont les enfants qui
sont les nôtres ceux qui vont venir ceux
qui vont qui seront la deuxième la
troisième génération appelée loi que
vous êtes en train de fabriquer la façon
dont ils vont recevoir ce que la
république ce que la nation dit de ce
que c'est que une filiation
encore une fois pas de ce que c'est
qu'une famille mais de ce que c'est
qu'une filiation j'ai eu l'occasion de
parler devant la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale et je disais que
par exemple dans un contexte qui était
celui d'une société patriarcale et d'une
société polygame le cinquième
commandement
non pas parce que je veux me référer à
la bible le comme argument d'autorité
mais c'est juste pour montrer que même à
cette époque et dans ce contexte social
le cinquième commandement dit dans une
société je répète qui est polygame sur
un os râteau père et ta mère ton père et
ta mère c'est à dire prend conscience du
fait que tu as un père et une mère
encore une fois c'est pas un argument
d'autorité c'est juste une analogie pour
faire comprendre que quel que soit le
cadre familial quelle que soit la façon
dont la famille se structurent ce sur
quoi nous pouvons porter l'accent c'est
sur la question de savoir comment un
enfant repérera qu'il a un père et une
mère car de toute façon ça a été dit ça
a été redit je le redis encore une fois
de toute façon un enfant quel qu'il soit
à un père et une mère
il n'existe pas d'enfant qui n'est pas
un père et une mère
alors j'ai entendu tout à l'heure d'un
bref échange de
auxquels j'ai assistés qui les rend
effectivement au fait que la structure
avait ce site autonome que si on me dit
si un des termes tous les autres termes
s'en trouve modifié mais il nous a été
répondu en quelque sorte qu'il y à des
avaries et lévi-strauss donc cette fois
un anthropologue et non ce n'est pas
n'importe lequel faisait remarquer dans
dans un de ses textes
la chose suivante il existe dix sept
îles une infinité variété des formes de
la parenté et vous savez à quel point
lévi strauss a travaillé sur les
structures élémentaires de la parenté
il existe une infinité variété des
formes de la parenté et de la
répartition des rôles sexuels et
disait-il lors d'un congrès sur le
travail des femmes
mais ce qui n'existe jamais c'est l'un
différenciation des sexes et si un
changement massif anthropologique majeur
qui fait que ça n'est comparable en rien
à tous les changements qui ont eu lieu
dans l'histoire de l'occident pour n'en
rester qu'à l'occident
si un changement anthropologique majeur
c'est que tout d'un coup la question de
la différence des sexes ne deviendrait
plus un enjeu majeur
on touche à la différence des sexes
c'est pas la même chose que le droit au
divorce
éventuellement le droit à l'avortement
cetera qui ne changeait pas qui ne
changeait pas fondamentalement la donne
de la constitution de la structure même
un des liens entre hommes et femmes
vu du point de vue d'un enfant perd
c'est là dessus que je vais me permettre
d'assister si vous si vous me autorisée
prenons partons si vous voulez de ce que
freud lui même considéré comme jusqu'à
la fin de son oeuvre dans la brèche et
psychanalyse qui est son dernier livre
publié comme le point pivot de la
doctrine ticket génétique à savoir le
dip sa mauvaise presse aujourd'hui le
dip
ça fait ringard ça fait dogmatique
ça fait même pour certains délires mais
enfin ce qu'on n'a pas ce sur quoi on
n'a pas suffisamment insisté quand on
parle de l'oedipe c'est qu'il y ait un
grande différence entre le dip tel que
nous le concevons dans le langage
courant
est ce que c'est que le dip du point de
vue du psychanalyste et pas seulement du
psychanalyste
excusez moi un peu chaud que dit que dit
le dip
du point de vue psychanalytique il
raconte quelque chose qui pour les
parlementaires écrivant la loi a une
importance me semble t'il capitale il
raconte l'histoire d'une loi qui
s'adresse à un sujet qui n'est pas un
sujet de droit et c'est ceux là dessus
que je voudrais insister le dip
l'interdît de l'oedipe son corollaire
qui est l'interdît de l'inceste
le deal s'adresse à l'enfant c'est à
l'enfant qu'il ai dit tu ne coucheras
pas avec ta mère je schématise
évidemment ce n'est pas l adulte
même si le législateur a cru bon
récemment d'introduire l'interdît de
l'inceste dans la loi je m'y étais
d'ailleurs à cette époque opposé car
l'interdît de l'inceste
s'il devient une loi de droit positif
une autre loi pourrait le défaire
c'est une loi qui est au dessus des lois
d'autant plus que j'insiste
elle s'adresse à quelqu'un qui n'est pas
un sujet de droit en lui demandant de
renoncer
assez vite assez tôt à ce qui est un
désir parle humanité partagée et ceci je
dis c'est un invariant historique
peut-être même un invariant à la fois
historique et géographiquement universel
de renoncer à ses premiers objets des
hits de désir c'est premier objet
d'amour pour pouvoir devenir un être
désirant c'est à dire un être tourné
vers l'avenir
on lui dit si tu veux désirer c'est à
dire si tu veux avoir un avenir
si tu veux te préoccuper du progrès
justement il faut que tu renonces aux
objets qui ont été les tient aux objets
de désir et d'amour qui ont été les
tiens quand tu étais dans son plus jeune
âge
c'est un paradoxe sur lequel il faut
insister c'est à l'enfant que ça
s'adresse mais l'enfance et chacun
d'entre nous est la question qui est
posée c'est à partir de là celle que je
me suis posée c'est celle ci quand
certains psychanalystes sont brocardés
par ce qu'ils font appel à ce dogme qui
serait le dip en dix ans mais que
va-t-il advenir de l'oedipe si l'enfant
est confronté seulement à 2-2 sommes
confrontés seulement à deux femmes
la question est mal posée me semble-t-il
s'il ya une question qui se pose sur le
plan se dit tiens c'est à propos des
gens qui imaginent de faire un enfant en
le privant soit de pair soit de mer
c'est là que se pose la question de l'
oedipe pas au niveau de l'enfant dont
ils auront la charge et dont je ne doute
pas qu'ils sont capables je vais y
revenir tout à l'heure qui seront
capables de s'en occuper sur le plan
éducatif et sur l'amour qu'ils sont à
même de lui donner c'est pas à ce niveau
là que ça se passe
c'est qu'elle est ce fantasme d'enfants
prêts oedipien
qui imagine que on pourrait faire un
enfant
en décidant que eh bien il aura pas de
papa ou bien il aura pas de maman et
alors on me dit oui mais alors là on ne
dit pas ce que vous adorez j'aurais
compris que c'est pas la première fois
que je les bats est conscient on me dit
mais là vous fantasmez alors pour le
compte pour le compte totalement les
homosexuels en couple
jamais ils ne diront des choses
pareilles aux enfants ils leur dirons
aux enfants d'antisant la charge il leur
dirons la vérité
il leur dira on est bien oui nous nous
sommes rencontrés nous avons décidé de
faire un enfant
mais pour ça il a fallu que nous ayons
recours un tiers tiers donneur ou
éventuellement grossesse pour autrui
dans le cadre d'un couple d'homosexuels
et puis quand on leur dit oui mais nous
avons des exemples clinique qui démontre
que tout ne se passe pas comme ça dans
le merveilleux est dans le champ de la
vérité tout entière dit
comme si c'était possible on nous dit
oui ils ce sont des anecdotes 1 ce sont
des cas marginaux mais nous devons
tabler sur la bonne foi de tout le monde
mais où at on vu qu'une loi s'instituait
en tablant sur la bonne foi de qui que
ce soit une loi est une loi et elle ne
se préoccupe absolument pas 2 d'ordonner
à qui que ce soit de dire la vérité on
veut pas on peut pas imaginer une loi
qui dise vous dirai la vérité aux
enfants dont vous avez la charge
j'ai entendu puisque je ne peux pas
faire référence à mon travail cynique
personnel pour des raisons de
déontologie évidente mais il ya des
choses que chacun d'entre nous peut
entendre dans les divers reportages qui
ont sont faits
en toute bonne foi et même je dirais
quelquefois de façon militante auprès
des dés couples homosexuels ou ou des
couples militants j'ai entendu par
exemple dans un tout récent reportage
donc c'est pas quelque chose qui date
d'il ya deux ans ou 10 à 3 ans dans un
tour une récent reportage des femmes
homosexuelles dire en toute bonne foi
mais comme le disait lacan l'erreur de
bonne foi et de toute la plus
impardonnable 1 tu n'as pas de papa
disait une des deux femmes un enfant de
2 ans tu n'as pas de papa tu as deux
mamans tu es né parce qu'on se met très
fort mais non je dire autorisée par la
loi que de tels propos puissent se tenir
alors qu'ils correspondent très
précisément à ce à quoi l'enfant est
confronté quotidiennement l'enfant
d'avant l'âge où il pourra résonner sur
ce qui lui arrive
le confronter à cela c'est le confronter
à ce que j'appellerais un mensonge
d'état
il y aura mensonge alors est ce qu'il ya
une parade
je disais à l'instant aucune loi ne peut
imposer à qui que ce soit de dire la
vérité
d'autant que cette vérité elle est
relativement insaisissable mais par
contre on peut très bien imaginer que
cette vérité à savoir que l'enfant a de
toute façon un père et une mère sous
quelque forme que ce soit
cette vérité elle peut être écrite dans
des documents qui vont faire foi qui
sont des documents d'état civil et
auquel l'enfant un jour ou un autre sera
confronté s'ils le souhaitent que par
exemple soient écrits sur l'acte de
naissance non pas la mention parce que
malheureusement elle a des relents un
peu passéistes né de père inconnu mais
une formule qui permette de dire
que l'enfant de les pannes lit du simple
fait de l'union de ces deux femmes c'est
une formule qui reste à inventer que
cette formule soit reportée aussi sur le
livret de famille et pas comme l'a
proposé à nos collègues en dédoublant ou
en des triples an le livret de famille
avec un livret de filiation un livret de
famille etc qui serait dé façon tout à
fait sur noye de stigmatiser les couples
homosexuels mais que sur le livret de
famille soit inscrit la réalité de la
procréation de façon à ce que combien
d'enfants avant que tout c'est toutes
ces histoires nous nous préoccupe
combien d'enfants ont appris qu'on leur
avait menti
simplement le jour où ils ont ouvert le
livret de famille à 14 15 16 17 ans ou
18 ans ou au moment de se marier par
exemple eh bien ce sera l'occasion pour
chacun de ses enfants d'être confronté à
quelque chose qui quelle que soit la
façon dont ça leur a été racontée leur
permettra de prendre écart de ces cartes
est quelque peu dé façon dont les choses
leur auront été racontée une dernière
chose si vous permettez je faisais
mention tout à l'heure de cette idée que
puisque des couples de même sexe sont
capables d'offrir à n'importe quel
enfant un amour au moins équivalent à
celui qu'offre une la famille
hétérosexuelle qui tout d'un coup
devient un concept alors que ça n'en
était pas un ils sont aussi capables de
les éduquer d'une manière tout à fait
respectable et honorable et d'une
certaine façon cela est versée sur le
compte de la psychanalyse
je voudrais dire que
freud déjà il est bon son souvenir
remarquer qu'on accorde beaucoup trop
d'importance à l'éducation dans le
développement de l'enfant et soutien
dans de nombreux textes d'une grande
partie de ce que nous devenons ne dépend
pas de l'éducation reçue en fait il est
bon de le rappeler parce que on met sur
le dos de la psychanalyse la toutes
sortes de choses qui ne sont pas de son
fait
en fait l'éducation peut jouer un rôle
déterminant mais essentiellement quand
elle joue un rôle négatif
lorsqu elle s'impose à contretemps des
réalité physiologique social et
psychologique
l'apprentissage par exemple de la
propreté ci survient avant la maturation
physiologiques des sphincters a des
conséquences psychologiques encombrante
pour l'enfant pour le dire de façon
douce l'assimilation de la sexualité
infantile qui est quand même une des
grandes découvertes de la psychanalyse
mais son assimilation à la sexualité
adulte constitue pour un enfant toujours
un véritable viol au contraire une
éducation bénéfique et celles qui
favorisent le sujet en favorisant son
potentiel physique physiologique et
social voilà pour aller travaux
préparatoires de la commission des lois
a travaux préparatoires à l'examen en
commission du projet de loi ouvrant le
mariage aux personnes de même sexe si
vous souhaitez revoir ses auditions
elles sont disponibles en vod sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr tout de
suite le journal de 19h présenté ce soir
par michel grossiord bonne soirée à tous